foi de ce mot cole merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
vous êtes vous-même à beyrouth
qu'est ce qu'on sème la situation
actuellement sur place est ce qu'on sait
s'il y a des victimes ont tout d'abord
merci beaucoup de suivre cette évolution
de traîneaux apprécions beaucoup parce
que finalement avoir les médias qui
couvrent ce drame que nous vivons tous
les jours que nous vivons depuis un
moment mais depuis toujours nous touche
parce que c'est le seul moyen de s'en
sortir donc finalement on a tous été
surpris par ce nouvel incendie quelques
2 e mois après le dramatique explosion
tragédie apocalypse qui lui a
complètement détruit notre ville jusqu'à
cet instant on n'a pas pu savoir mais
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas
d'informations de blessés ou de morts
mais je ne vous cache pas qu'il ya une
panique générale dans le pays on entend
des ambulances on entend des pompiers
qui vont mais toujours des pompiers qui
ont très peur à savoir que la plupart
des pompiers pour ne pas dire tous les
pompiers qui sont allés il ya un mois
pour essayer d'éteindre l'incendié du
port sont partis en morceaux
malheureusement on le trouve même plus
le reste donc il ya aussi une peur que
dramatique
l'armée a fermé certaines routes pour
empêcher de passants ou de certains
curieux de venir mais je vous ne vous
cache pas qu'il ya beaucoup de panique
mais en même temps on est très dérangé
de ce qui se passe parce que une fois de
plus ça prouve la mauvaise gestion la
mauvaise gouvernance la mauvaise
transparence qui se passe c'est vraiment
dramatique qu à ce niveau une fois de
plus après un mois d'une explosion qui
la troisième plus grande explosion du
monde
on a un incendie qui au même moment bon
d'un côté on sait que c'est on a su que
c'est beaucoup plus des pneus ou de
l'huile qui a qui a pris feu mais je ne
vous cache pas que si c'est une incident
criminel pour cacher certaines preuves
c'est dramatique
et si c'est un incident par accident
c'est encore pire c'est à dire que
jusqu'à cet instant
nos forces ne sont pas à pouvoir au même
protégé quand même les pouvoirs publics
justement froides aux manquements l'on
sait qu'un feu de déchets limité 1 s'est
également déclarée hier en fin d'après
midi toujours au port de beyrouth
cette zone elle n'est pas du tout
surveiller aujourd'hui écoutez je peux
vous dire que quand on dit un port mais
en porc et surveiller c'est un set c'est
un terrain qui appartient à l'état c'est
un terrain qui est sous surveillance une
protection des employés de l'état
donc normalement c'est supposé être le
quartier le plus surveillé de beyrouth
surtout après une explosion donc on peut
même pas y arriver pour savoir ce qui
s'est passé donc je peux vous dire que
si c'est extrêmement surveillé voilà
pourquoi j'étais justement en train de
dire que si c'est un incendie qui a été
de criminels pour cacher certaines
peuvent c'est dramatique mais si c'est
aussi un autre accident ça encore plus
dramatique et ça prouve au monde entier
que malheureusement nous ne sommes pas
capables de protéger le port les
aéroports et qu'on a besoin d'une
intervention internationale pour nous
aider donc seulement à passer outre
notre problème économique et financier
mais aussi politiques et autres et pour
la surveillance de toutes nos frontières
dans le port les aéroports et autres
c'est dramatique ça se passe encore une
fois et il faut pas oublier que c'est un
mois après la g atik explosion qui a
quand même causé la mort de puisque 200
personnes six mille civils morts et 300
mille sans abri on n'oubliera jamais
cette explosion ni cet acte pour les
annales
et à l'heure où on se parle est ce que
les mots les médias locaux évoquent des
pistes concernant cet incendie regardez
franchement jusqu'à maintenant on peut
pas parler de piste parce que comme vous
voyez à l'écran
les pompiers sont encore en train
d'éteindre les flammes c'est très
difficile de pouvoir mettre des doigts
d'accusation mais finalement une fois de
plus la plus grande à l'accusation c'est
un autre état
je dois rappeler devant vos médias que
c'est un terrain qui est sous
surveillance de l'état et de supposées
être complètement protégé et avoir ça
une fois de plus comme vous voyez avec
une panique générale et inacceptables
inacceptables
je le redis donc ça montre mal
malheureusement la mauvaise gestion la
mauvaise gouvernance la mauvaise
transparence et je vous dis très
honnêtement si jusqu'à maintenant après
un mois de la première explosion on ne
sait pas tout ce qui s'est passé
on ne sait pas ce qui a provoqué cette
explosion donc je doute qu'on puisse
savoir ce qui a provoqué ces flammes et
cet incendie ont fait pas confiance à
toute investigation mais je dois crier
très haut et très fort
le désarroi d'une population
complètement anéanti qui ne s'est pas
réveillé encore de son drame de cette
tragédie
cc c'est dramatique une fois de plus et
je fais appel à votre antenne à la
communauté internationale pour un
support et une interview
don direct pour la protection de ce pays
des entreprises et d'une population
complètement perdu pour conclure à vous
entendre en quelques mots on imagine
lorsqu'on vous écoute que ce nouvel
incendie va cristalliser à nouveau les
tensions dans le pays
oui et côté l'école et les tensions les
tensions cela il faut aussi savoir que
cet incendie et arrivent à l'heure où
nous avons un premier ministre nommé qui
en train de former son gouvernement
je suppose que ceci va pousser à une
formation rapide d'un gouvernement bon
parce que c'est impossible de pouvoir
générer subissant un pouvoir exécutif
donc je suppose que d'un point de vue
plus ou moins positif d'être ça va
pousser à la nomination 2010 mais en
même temps je peux vous dire que
hautmont complètement de protection de
gouvernance de tout ce point j'espère de
tout coeur que le ministre premier
ministre désigné l'équipe sohrab pourra
mettre quand même une protection sur
toutes ses frontières mais je ne vous
cache pas on a beaucoup perdu la
confiance la population les expatriés la
communauté internationale a complètement
perdu confiance en un état qui ne fait
que prouver de plus en plus sa mauvaise
gestion et son banque ne pouvoir
vraiment surveiller assurer une
protection générale à une population
complètement anéantie et désemparé merci
fois deux mots cole d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise
libanais dans le monde qui vous étiez
donc en liaison avec tous depuis
beyrouth